we are joined now by the state
department's undersecretary for
political affairs victoria newlands she
was also ambassador to nato under the
second bush administration so she knows
this subject area very well ambassador
newland thank you for joining us
i want to get to that first question
about the direction of the crisis is it
escalating or de-escalating what's the
latest
tony even though president putin is
claiming he's withdrawing our concern is
that the troops that matter those that
are ringing ukraine to the north to the
east and to the south are actually
increasing their readiness
so he is maintaining every option to go
in at a time of his choosing
so it sounds like from your perspective
we're still in a crisis or escalation
phase of this not de-escalation
there was a cyber attack on the
ukrainian army and two banks in the
country yesterday is it the belief of
the u.s government that that was putin
laying the groundwork potentially for a
broader assault
well we're still investigating and and
doing forensics along with the
ukrainians i think what's most important
is that these cyber attacks were not
very successful they were the both the
ministry of defense and the banks were
able to re-establish in real time and
that is a direct result of the hard work
that the ukrainians have been doing with
our help to make themselves resilient
but who is best at that this who uses
this weapon all around the world
obviously the kremlin
ambassador we cover this story every day
we have for weeks now but for the
average american sitting at home who
wants to understand why this former
soviet republic halfway around the world
seems to be so important to the current
administration what do you say to them
what i say to them is if
an authoritarian leader anywhere in the
world is able to invade their neighbor
and take them over by force and deny
them sovereignty then this won't end at
ukraine it'll happen all around the
world china is watching vis-a-vis taiwan
iran is watching north korea is watching
so we have to maintain u.n principles of
international law that protect the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
every single country notably including
ukraine that is the front line of the
democracies versus the autocracies
competition at this moment
ambassador uh uh president putin's goal
here to the best uh we can understand it
is to limit the encroachment of nato on
russia's border so the eastern expansion
of nato uh
why is it so important for nato to
continue to move in that direction and
is it your concern that putin could take
ukraine today but then move to rebuild
essentially the former soviet union in
the future
nato is a defensive alliance its purpose
since its founding in 1949 is to protect
the security of its
members so if you are not coming for us
we are not coming for you and in fact
nato never even had any forces on its
eastern edge in poland or the baltic
states until after russia took crimea
and invaded eastern ukraine so this is a
conflict of russia's own making
ambassador i know that the u.s
government does not want to detail what
the sanctions will be against putin and
russia if there is an invasion however i
am curious to know why you are confident
sanctions will work or could work in
this scenario given they have not been
successful in prior conflicts i'm
thinking of crimea
tony what we are preparing this time
with the european union and other allies
and partners around the world including
the uk and canada will be absolutely
crushing financially for russia and in
terms of russia's ability uh to grow its
economy and modernize going forward so
you know not only will this be a bloody
awful conflict for ukraine and for the
russian people it will also throw russia
back into isolation for a very very long
time you asked me a question about
rebuilding the soviet union union this
is the concern that putin has
a revolutionist fantasy about rebuilding
the former soviet union whether it's it
starts with ukraine it includes belarus
it could go as far as moldova and that
will throw not only europe but the world
back into a cold war posture and that's
what we're trying to prevent and that's
why we want
uh to see diplomacy succeed here and
while we're continuing to press that
with putin and with everybody else on
the russian side
and to avoid as you put it a bloody
awful conflict ambassador newland thank
you
thank you tony all right